sam fisher is back for real this time
plus we're going to talk about call of
duty crushing cheaters and fixing bugs
it's happening cure that scene from the
office because it's official and it's
happening ubisoft has revealed that 2002
splinter cell will be getting a remake
with efforts led by ubisoft toronto
splinter cell will be rebuilt from the
ground up using ubisoft's own snowdrop
engine which is currently also being
used for the company's upcoming star
wars and avatar games ubisoft says the
splinter cell remake will feature
dynamic lighting and shadows which will
be incorporated into the game's level
design spinoza will also be a linear
experience as ubisoft added that sam
fisher's return won't take place in an
open world what's different is how
fisher moves through this world the
game's technical producer added that
exploration and innovation will be key
pillars of the new splinter cell the
studio is looking to redefine what
stealth action gameplay should be for
more modern gaming audiences but don't
expect the remake to arrive soon it's
still in the early stages of development
ubisoft toronto is currently building
its team and plans to establish a new
foundation for splinter cell's future
so do you love warzone but you hate
cheaters well you're in luck because
ricochet the new anti-cheap protocol for
the call of duty games has been released
globally for call of duty warzone on pc
an official blog post says quote the pc
kernel level driver for ricochet
anti-cheat is one element of a
multi-faceted anti-cheat security
initiative and according to an official
faq posted by activision the quote
kernel level driver term refers to a
piece of code that has high level access
to a player's computer while the
software is running including the pc's
hardware according to the blog a normal
game operates on a user level and has
limited access to the kernel level and
other user mode processes meaning that
ricochet grants more access than a
normal game the program only works for
warzone on pc at the moment with no
timetable on when it will come to call
of duty's other game vanguard
in other cod news the latest weekly
patch for warzone has gone live it's the
first for the game's newest map and
there are a few big changes coming among
the major fixes are the removal of areas
where players could see and shoot
through certain objects on the field
another fix will prevent players from
using an exploit that allowed players to
duplicate weapons another big change
from this patch involves the automaton
assault rifle which is seeing its recoil
increase and move speed decreased for a
6.5 millimeter sakura 75 round drum
attachment making players slower when
using it for full patch notes head on
over to gamespot.com but before you do
that hit the comment section and let me
know how you're celebrating this
splinter cell announcement
you've got to be hyped if you're a fan
like after all the rumors you now it's
official you gotta be hyped i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
you